well good evening Fernando welcome to
Facebook and uncensored it wasn't so
long ago that when teachers asked
children what they want to be they meant
what profession now they're asking them
which animal object or beast they may
identify as and tethering their lessons
accordingly it's just satire it's a
genuine story it's true it's going on in
schools up and down the country and for
those of us who have warned for years
about the inevitable consequence of
Limitless self-identity it sadly won't
come as a surprise but it is shocking
this Story begins with a video that
circulated yesterday of a teacher in
England scolding two pupils for refusing
to accept that one of their classmates
identified as a cat
crazy
oh it wasn't a question I was just
saying about the gender I didn't say
anything about them there's only two
gender gender is not linked to do with
them
gender is about how you identify there
is actually pretty large
she can be born with male and female
body parts in terms of gender there are
lots of candy
which is really despicable
despicable so the age of 13 those
students who were wise enough to express
honestly held opinion which is one most
people in the world would share or for
that their own teacher says they're
despicable and if they hold that view
they should go to a different school
that view being that girls have vaginas
and boys have penises that's so
despicable they would have to leave the
school
I think was Despicable in that exchange
is what that teacher said the daily
telegrapher they followed up were
interviewing pupils of schools across
the United Kingdom for a major
investigation it read like a fast that
they made it up but it was actually true
they came up with all sorts of examples
from all over the country that looked
like we were living on frankly a
different planet to the one that most of
us think we're living on
which makes sense because some of the
kids they write about are identifying as
alien life forms literally on a
different planet
they said that children in high schools
have been allowed to self-identity as
cats horses dinosaurs even a moon not
the Moon
a moon and they're deadly serious about
this
Optimus causes disruption in lessons and
Telegraph reported because in some cases
they'll only communicate in animal
noises
pupils at schools where children
identify as cats complain to the
newspaper that classes are dominated by
the children because they insist on
meowing
this is not a joke this is serious
one people at a state Secondary School
in Wales so the fellow people feel very
discriminated against if you do not
refer to them as catself
Telegraph discovered that the people at
one high school is insisting on being
addressed as a dinosaur another as a
horse one where the cable wants to be
acknowledged like I said as a moon
the children are allowed to wear items
like cats ears while other human
identifying children are rebuked for
untucked shirts well enough is enough
put it this way what would you feel if I
said I'm a cat
seriously I do actually feel quite
feline I took in two kittens in January
my first pets I've had since I was a
teenager uh two little Burmese kittens
called Dennis and Bobby for Arsenal fans
named after berkamp and Pires and I
frankly now feel like one of them
to like identify as a cat I I snack a
lot I enjoy regular naps I have higher
than average intelligence I'm curious
and inquisitive I have a natural born
predatory instinct when it comes to
attacking Rivals to attack me and
everywhere I go people want to stroke my
chin and call me cute so yes I'm a cat
but there's one problem
I'm a human really I'm not actually a
cat
scientifically and biologically I'm a
human being
incontrovertibly it's a fact
much as I'd like to enjoy the benefits
of being a cat 20 hours naps no taxes
Meals On Demand when I cry I can't
because I'm not a cat
now if all of this is shocking to you
it's probably because you haven't been
paying attention most of these teachers
are probably trying to do the right
thing terrified of being reported for
bigotry for failing to indulge the
gender whims of children and the
children themselves are grown up in a
world where they're literally taught
there are hundreds of genders and
anybody can identify as anything they
want
but they can't
and when something like this happens
Society changes so radically and so fast
and becomes so ridiculous that it causes
complete chaos and we surely should be
questioning this it cannot simply be the
case that minority groups are right end
of question and anyone who raises
questions about it is automatically a
bigot or a transphob I'm not bigoted or
transphobic
but I do think this is insanity and the
next time a child identifies as a cat at
school in this country they should be
told but as a mark of deep respect for
their new identity they will be taken
out of the classroom put in a cage with
other actual cats who will scratch and
bite them all day they'll be given water
whiskers tuna chunks for lunch taken for
walks on leads and break time and must
use a litter tray for a toilet one that
won't be changed for several days trust
me they'll soon be re-identifying as
humans by tea time